[Music]
the blue Hedgehog is coming back to the
big screen two years after the sequel
Sonic 2 grows over $400 million
worldwide the trio consisting of Sonic
Tails and Knuckles is returning in Sonic
the Hedgehog 3 they'll have to face a
very special opponent that fans of the
video games have been eagerly waiting
for in this original you can learn
everything you need to know regarding
the story cast and production of Sonic 3
enjoy let's kick off with a brief recap
of the second movie before moving on to
the potential storyline of part three
Sonic is attacked by The Returned
Robotnik and his new ally this is
Knuckles who driven by the search for
the Master Emerald has sided with
Robotnik except for him all the members
of his Akida tribe are extinct thus he
sees it as his calling to come into
possession of this ancient and Powerful
Relic fortunately Sonic is rescued by
its friend miles prow Alias tails and
manages to escape from robotnik's
clutches eventually Sonic manages to
convince tails to track down the
mysterious Relic Which is far too
powerful to fall into wrong hands in the
meantime Robotnik and Knuckles find the
emerald in an underwater temple where
the two finally face off again during
the combat Robotnik secretly escapes
with the emerald and absorbs its power
now Knuckles also realizes that he was
only being used by Robotnik and so from
now on he joins Sonic and Tails in the
fight against the evil doctor he has
meanwhile created a giant robot and is
destroying Green Hills the trio manages
to get the Master Emerald back although
it shatters into the seven Chaos
Emeralds after Sonic through his new
form as Super Sonic is able to destroy
the robot and apparently Robotnik as
well Knuckles reassembles the seven
stones into one and the three new
friends live happily ever after in the
home of Tom and
Maddie there was a lot of speculation
among fans beforehand about possible
storylines for the new movie several
theories were already circulating the
web shortly after the sequel was
announced for example about an
appearance by Metal Sonic who was
developed by Dr Robotnik to transfer
Sonic's Powers into a robot Metal Sonic
is considered one of the blue Hedgehog's
toughest opponents and as a firm goal
namely to destroy his living equivalent
the concept of SuperSonic known from the
games could also play a bigger role
after all he already used the chaos
emeralds at the end of part two to gain
special
powers however the mid-credit scene of
the previous movie reveals what the
third Adventure will most likely be
about in this scene the new antagonist
for part three is revealed namely Shadow
the Hedgehog the character was first
introduced in the video game Sonic
Adventure 2 and a SE as an anti-hero
created by Dr robotnik's grandfather the
character originated from Project Shadow
which was carried out around 50 years
before the events in Sonic 2 it is a
research program of the United
Federation which is based on today's
United States and is the Home Country of
the gun military organization the final
product of this experiment are two
creatures that are almost Immortal
biolizard and Shadow the Hedgehog after
the creation of Shadow however the
project was scraped due to its dangerous
nature Maria Robotnik was shot by a gun
Soldier while trying to flee Shadow
which led to her grandfather becoming a
villain who wanted to wipe out the world
in Revenge for the movie Sonic the
Hedgehog 3 this could mean that we will
have to deal with robotnik's grandfather
and his granddaughter Maria in
flashbacks at least incidentally Maria
is one of the few people Shadow is not
hostile towards shadow looks very much
like Sonic and is considered one of his
greatest Rivals although he often
exhibits an arrogant attitude he's also
one of the most profound characters in
the Sonic Universe revealing his
vulnerable nature only to a few author
Patrick Casey who wrote the scripts for
the first two films described Shadow as
a worthy opponent for Sonic he is driven
by anger and Vengeance and is therefore
not simply a misguided character like
Knuckles once was this could make it all
the more difficult for Sonic to deter
Shadow from pursuing his plans in part
three with the introduction of Shadow
Rouge the bad is also likely to make an
appearance she is a treasure hunter and
spy for gun who often works together
with Shadow Knuckles in particular is
often the target of her her attention
she seems to enjoy arguing with him but
is also after his Master Emerald she
enjoys using her feminine charms and
could make an exciting sidekick for the
villain Shadow in Sonic
3 in addition to the new foes we could
also see the appearance of Amy Rose
however Amy is not the hero's enemy but
a bright and cheerful Hedgehog girl who
falls in love with Sonic the first clues
about her appearance in Sonic 3 were
given during a Q&A session with
screenwriters Patrick Casey and Josh
Miller when asked whether Amy might
appear in the third part the two did not
answer with the no instead they gave a
rather open clue that her appearance was
in the works it's understandable that
the two couldn't reveal much just a few
weeks after the release of Sonic 2 her
appearance would certainly be a good fit
for the sequel so that there was another
Ally for the hero besides the new
antagonist the dynamic between her and
her Crush should make for some funny
moments even though she sometimes has
quite a few mood swings and is totally
obsessed with her great love she would
surely provide active support to the
existing Trio in the fight against
Shadow and the others despite her often
innocent nature she is a powerful Ally
who can certainly match her friends one
of her favorite weapons is the Pico Pico
Hammer used by Amy for self-defense and
which grows in size the angrier she
gets then Schwarz will once again be
voicing the blue Hedgehog Idris Elba and
Keno shanesy will also return in the
roles as Knuckles and Tails as for the
humans James Marsden will be back as Tom
and Tika Sumpter as his wife Maddie
along with her lovely sister Rachel
played by Natasha
Rothwell what will happen to Dr Robotnik
played by Jim Carrey remains unclear
Carrie announced in an interview in 2022
that he intended to retire from acting
after Sonic 2 for good some people hope
that he might take on the challenge of a
third part after all but their
expectations are rather low with Shadow
as a new antagonist from the past Dr
Robotnik himself could actually be
omitted somewhat smartly after all
Shadow's story is more related to the
family of Jim carre's character the
61-year-old actor may be tempted to make
a small Cameo but it is unlikely that he
will make a bigger appearance the two
producers of the film series Toby Asher
and Neil Moritz have already confirmed
that they do not want to replace the
character whatsoever Not only would that
be disrespectful towards Carrie but it
would also cause a huge storm which
they wanted to avoid at all costs we all
remember the debacle of the first
trailer for part one where the look of
the character was the cause of horror
and a lot of ridicule online since Sonic
3 is supposed to focus more on the CGI
characters according to the producers
the human parts will presumably play a
rather minor function anyway another
factor that speaks against a return of
Dr Robotnik
filming on Sonic 3 has been well
underway since September 2023 in
contrast to many other Productions work
on the movie continued even during the
actor strike in Hollywood the crew
simply shot the scenes in which CGI
characters in particular will make an
appearance first without the
participation of the real actors the
filming location in London proved to be
extremely beneficial as there are no
picketing guidelines in the UK that
would have prevented production without
the actors as the strike has now ended
filming can now continue with the actors
without any
interruptions Sonic the Hedgehog 3 will
be released in theaters on December 20th
2024 unlike the previous installments
the new Hedgehog adventure is therefore
not coming in Spring but during the
Christmas period the first Sonic 3
trailer will thus likely be a while
incoming in the meantime though there's
another Sonic production that fans can
look forward
to besides Sonic 3 the spin-off series
Knuckles is awaiting us next year for
which Idris Elba will reprise the role
of the titular character it will be
available for streaming on Paramount
plus but an exact release date hasn't
been set it comes as no surprised that
the popular character is getting his own
spin-off after all Knuckles has already
featured in as many as 101 video games
the popularity of the Sonic character
also seems undiminished even before the
2020 and 2022 movies there were an
impressive 396 Sonic games and five
animated series already according to
producer Toby Asher should the two new
projects prove to be successful an
entire Sonic Cinematic Universe is under
construction with further movies and
series to follow in an interview with
comicbook.com director Jeff Fowler also
expressed his wish to direct a Smash
Brothers movie in which the most famous
characters in video game history would
compete against each other well that
would be
exciting that was our latest update on
Sonic 3 what do you expect from the
third part are there any game elements
that you have missed on the big screen
so far we look forward to your thoughts
in the comments and would appreciate
your thumbs up if you enjoyed this video
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]
oh